I'm Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight thanks so
much for being with us
gruesome Newsome comes after Fox
Primetime host including yours truly I
will respond so stay tuned for that
but first wave elections that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now it's not just the arrival of crisp
fall weather there's other big change in
the air as well and it could tell us a
lot about how things will play out here
in the November midterms in Italy exit
polls show Europe's hard right has
scored another stunning success at The
Ballot Box who couldn't
thanks Whedon
party with right wing neo-fascist Roots
would now be dominant in in Parliament
in France that the right-wing parties
would make such a strong showing under
Marine Le Pen
it turns out that regular working people
are growing increasingly fed up with
establishment politicians not just here
but abroad as well
so Italy's new prime minister Giorgio
Maloney is a first as she's the first
woman ever to be elected prime minister
there
now you think about it our press is
usually over the moon when the first is
a liberal woman or a minority or gay
but not in this case
Italy has elected its first female prime
minister note this though she is set to
lead the most far-right government in
that country since Mussolini for the
first time since World War II and the
fall of Benito Mussolini Italy will have
a far-right government party with roots
in neo-fascism the fiery 45 year old is
comfortable with some of the Hallmarks
of Italian fascism like this motto
Fatherland and family
now three things the media despise God
fathers and the nuclear family I mean
this is just ridiculous if any group
today comes close to Mussolini and his
brutal Infamous use of big business and
big government together
it's the modern left so nice try kids
of course the reason this first in Italy
does not count is because she doesn't
play their globalist game she refuses to
she hasn't been bought off instead she
calls out the failures of the majority
parties and refuses to submit to their
woke Crusade against national identity
and National culture this was Maloney
back in 2019.
why is the family Anatomy why is the
family so frightening because it defines
us because it defines our identity and
so they attack national identity they
attack religious identity they attack
gender identity they attack family
identity I can't Define myself as
Italian Christian woman mother I must be
citizen X gender X parent one parent two
I must be a number because when I am
only a number when I no longer have an
identity or Roots then I will be the
perfect Slave at the mercy of financial
speculators the perfect consumer
well I suggest that you watch her entire
speech it is fantastic I'm going to post
it tonight on Laura ingram.com
now the fact is Europe is facing a
largely self-inflicted energy crisis
this winter it's going to be horrific
although it's easier just to blame Putin
of course and Europe has struggled with
a stampede of migrants from the Middle
East and North Africa remember this was
forced on them by the EU years ago
especially in Sweden
the burden on Social Services schools
and law enforcement there has been
nightmarish now crimes unlike anything
the police have reported before in
Sweden including bombings have become
commonplace
these humiliation crimes they have
increased the last years we also call it
domination violence where a young person
can be urinated at at gunpoint tortured
for hours just because uh he's a Swede
and there is such resentment among some
people
now this is overwhelmed the once a very
Placid country
so how can anyone blame the Swedish
people for finally voting to try to stop
this madness
to not do so would be insane
something of a national death wish
and as the passage of brexit was a
Bellwether in 2016 for Trump could the
recent populist victories across Europe
predict similar GOP midterm successes
well the Grim faces on the faux
intellectual class seems to indicate yes
the the victory of a party that has its
roots in Italian fascism
plain and simple is concerning to
everybody uh it accompanies as you said
this move in Europe there is this
populist Rage that's sweeping across
Europe much as it swept Across America
in the in the 2016 election
however at real reporting here
so those people who are serenely tucked
away in their safe enclaves of their own
they simply dismiss these developments
out of hand
their analysis whiffs of a cursory
Wikipedia search it's lazy
the same Dynamic is playing out there
well populist candidates and the America
First policies that worked under Trump
were and are roundly ridiculed and
resisted Without Really any substantive
argument by those same people
if there's literally almost nothing when
you look at it nothing the bipartisan
establishment and especially now the
Democrats
nothing they've touched that they
haven't screwed up
the energy sector now we're all facing
these skyrocketing Energy prices just in
time for the great freeze here in the
United States and in Europe of course
Foreign Affairs they threw Russia into
the arms of China with their idiotic
handling of Ukraine
and then of course the climate change
Obsession trillions borrowed trillions
printed and eventually will be spent on
green Marxist policies that'll just Rob
us of our freedom and our prosperity
yeah we're all watching the financial
markets down down all of this is
dragging us into a global recession
you know the past few years have
strained and tested our transatlantic
relationship
but the United States is determined
determined to re-engage with Europe
to consult with you to earn back our
position of trusted leadership
well yeah the European Elites they
loathed Trump as America First policies
and they were thrilled to hold hear
those kinds of words from Biden when he
won
but how are things feeling now boys and
girls
but being a radical globalist means
never having to say you're sorry or
frankly never having to change your mind
about anything
not for foreign policy disasters like
the Afghanistan pull out or on domestic
policy with the coveted school closures
still feel comfortable with the way that
school districts even you know in your
home state handled the pandemic
I think we were under unprecedented
times at that point where people really
were struggling to figure out what was
the best thing to do to make sure that
their kids their families their children
were safe remember people were dying
I don't even recognize Patty Murray
she's going to be defeated by Tiffany
Smiley by the way in Washington state so
look with listening to Patty Marie she
can't offend her paymaster the teachers
unions even when the teachers unions
cruelly sacrificed our children's
learning for their own convenience and
their own power
so there's only so long even The Bluest
of blue Estates like Washington State
Oregon even New England where
law-abiding Americans are going to
tolerate ghoulish scenes like this
okay
look when you aren't safe
you aren't free
but again the party in power doesn't
believe it Bears any responsibility
so here's the reality
the Press can try to keep spinning away
this populist Awakening happening here
and in Europe but it's not going to help
them
The Establishment here like over there
it's out of ideas they can't fix the
economy they can't stop crime they can't
see the nuclear danger in Ukraine they
can't or won't stop the Border invasion
and Americans don't like losers and over
time they will turn to officials who can
actually deliver positive results
the future I think belongs to places
like Texas Florida Virginia Tennessee
Iowa and other parts of America where
state governments are actually working
to improve the lives of their people
what a novel concept
so the question every American has to
ask is this
do you want to be on the winning side or
do you want to go down with the sour
pushes like Liz Cheney and Nancy Pelosi
do you want to feel safe again
or do you want to worry about crime
do you want to make money or do you want
to watch your 401k disappear
there's a wave coming
and it's never too late to take up
surfing
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else